the world's first ever malaria vaccine
got a thumbs up from the world health
organization this morning the wh says
children in africa should get the shots
from glax glaxo smith klein to try and
prevent millions of illnesses every year
deborah patta shows how this decision
could have a huge impact on public
health
good morning describing this new vaccine
as ground breaking is something of an
understatement here in africa it really
could mean the difference between life
and death
we have bed nets to stop mosquito bites
and drugs to kill the parasites and yet
malaria remains one of the most deadly
diseases on the planet so it's no wonder
the world health organization regards
this as a game changer
this vaccine is a gift to the world
but its value will be felt most in
africa malaria kills around half a
million people every year more than 50
percent are children and nearly all
those cases are in sub-saharan africa
the new vaccine has been given to more
than 800 000 african children since 2019
in a pilot program one of its
ingredients is from a rare chilean
evergreen tree clinical trials showed a
30 percent efficacy but when combined
with anti-malarial drugs there was a 70
reduction in deaths
in a year of unparalleled medical
breakthroughs it's easy to become blase
about another new vaccine but this one
could change the course of history
deborah patter reporting there with some
life-changing news particularly for kids
in africa